[Music]
yes
and let us pray
almighty God
as we celebrate the birth of our nation
may we never take the freedoms we enjoy
today for granted
we are mindful of the countless men and
women in uniform
would have given their lives
so that we can live as a free people
help us to live always in your light
so that the rights of life
Liberty
and the pursuit of happiness enshrined
in our Declaration of Independence
May Inspire us
to work toward creating a more perfect
union
each
free day of Our Lives
bless the men and women in our military
and their family members
regularly make sacrifices
in order to serve our country
and for those who have made the ultimate
sacrifice
grant them a place in your kingdom
where they may know peace and joy in
your presence
all eternity
we make this prayer in your holy name
amen
and now it is my honor to introduce the
first lady of the United States Dr Jill
Biden
[Applause]
and thank you to The Uso for helping you
make this event so special and for being
such a great partner to my White House
Journey forces initiative that supports
military and Veteran families caregivers
and survivors
secretary Austin
Julene my fellow military families
thank you
all across the country the bases around
the world people are gathering with
family and friends to celebrate the
birth of our nation
but even as we laugh with our nation
neighbors and enjoy the parades and
cookouts and fireworks we can never lose
sight of the freedoms that this day
represents
for the families who make that freedom
possible
families like all of you
you are the grave and the Bold and the
nearly one percent of Americans who have
made the choice to keep us all safe
you miss births and birthdays graduation
and weddings because you choose to put
our country's security above your own
and you're the spouses and children who
serve as well saying goodbye to friends
and jobs losing sleep when your service
member is away putting your chin up and
your shoulders back no matter what this
country asks of you we are so grateful
for all that you do
and our thoughts are with those serving
overseas
as a military mom and as your first lady
I am honored and proud to share today
with you and I'm proud to be part of
this military family God bless our
troops and their families and have a
happy Fourth of July
[Applause]
my husband President Joe Biden
happy forth
today we celebrate our independence
celebrate our Liberty
and our freedom
Jill and I are honored to spend the day
with so many military families
we represent the link in the chain of
Honor
the stretches back to our founding days
you are the sinew the backbone the
reality of why we're Who We Are
I'm breaking unbending
throughout our history remind us that
democracy is never never never
guaranteed
every generation
must fight to maintain it must always
cherish it
defended and strengthened
you know as we remember the
extraordinary country this is I hope we
all rededicate ourselves to the
essential work of our democracy which is
to unify to unify unify this nation
see each other not as adversaries
the fellow Americans
let us remember that well the Other
Nation performed based on things like
geography ethnicity religion America is
the only nation in history founded on an
idea
an idea
that is that we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all people are created
equal all people
rights
among them life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
we haven't always lived up to those
words
we've never walked away from them
today
and all days
we have to say clearly we never will we
never will
this year
the honor the 15th anniversary of the
all-voluntary force
50 years
75th anniversary of desegregating
military
75th anniversary of women's official
integration into the military full blown
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you know we just have to keep the faith
and we just have to remember who we are
we are the United States of America and
there's nothing nothing beyond our
capacity if we work together
ladies and gentlemen we've come out of
every single solitary crisis stronger
than we went in
247 years that's not hyperbole that's a
fact but the only nation that has so
folks happy Fourth of July God bless you
and may God protect our troops thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]